[Music]
in get with the times
news submitted by Tiger oh really
finally a hotel owner went online to
roast a social-media influencer after
she requested free accommodations Oh
what like she demanded free [ __ ] that's
different yeah can I tell you guys
something real quick
this actually happens a lot at barbell
there's a lot of people that come in
because they're like they think they're
a fitness influencer what they got like
50 followers yeah I know you don't know
why I'm let me know feel free we
actually get that a lot
people are like 10,000 followers 5,000
and what's funny is our guest passes on
and oh but the real guys like the real
big guys million 10 million don't care
they just pay me like I understand like
I'm not even trying to feel that car
because you know why I'm a real player
in the game and I pay for barbell
membership to support the homie oh thank
you do you really mean just split it how
about that two people I gave myself a
discount meaning just split how about
that I think that's what it does is
freak yeah I'm like I could have sworn
yours that's my duty shirt dude how
about that we split it how how about
that's right even Kate
yeah that one drove how about it how
about it how about that how about that
period very 16 we spend about about the
English normal English okay how about
that how about that oh I thought was Bo
W so this story revolves around this
blogger her name is Ellie
okay ain't cheap as [ __ ] alright so
this is the email so this is the email
that she sent this hotel so it says hi
there
I hope this email finds you well I'm
emailing in regards to a possible
collaboration on social media my name is
redacted not a minute I work as a
social-media influencer mainly lifestyle
beauty and travel based I have over
eighty seven thousand YouTube
subscribers and it's just it's a link to
her YouTube as well as 76,000 Instagram
followers my partner and I are planning
to come to Dublin for an early
Valentine's Day weekend from February
8th to the 12th to explore the area as I
was searching for places to stay I came
across your stunning hotel and would
love to feature you in my YouTube videos
/ dedicated Instagram stories / post to
bring traffic to your hotel and
recommend others to book up and return
for free accommodation last year I
worked with Universal Orlando in Florida
and it's been amazing for them let me
know if this is something you'd be
interested in doing I look forward to
hearing from you
oh I had her so wrong that's that's your
professional it's very professional
I'm worse than this way worse than this
would ya you want me to hook you up guys
are very professional that's way
different the people I just show up cuz
the people that show up at bar but
they're literally like this hmmm serious
yeah like you guys know what to do right
5,000 followers you know it's you that's
entitled yeah that's it's this sounds
like a straight-up professional
collaborative this opportunity yeah
it's like you could simply say well no
thanks we're good yeah exactly and so
the response here so she never got a
direct response from the the owner
instead she found out like she ended up
opening her Twitter and there was a ton
of mention she's like what the heck is
happening
oh no this hotel here they posted the
email and then like like you can see
here they blurt it out but they blurt it
out and like an airbrush type of thing
where it's so light that if you just
bump up the brightness you could see
exactly what's written so then a lot of
people already knew it like they that's
why they found her this is a great
professional email though and it's like
it's like hey no worries if you can't
you know yeah so then this is this is
the response from the hotel just read it
it's called though the white mousse cafe
dear social influencer I know your name
but apparently it's not important to use
names thank you for your email looking
for free accommodation returned for
exposure it takes a lot of balls in an
email like that if not my self-respect
and dignity what the [ __ ] if I let you
stay here and return for a feature in
your video who is going to pay the staff
to look after you who is gonna pay the
housekeeper to clean a room the waiters
who serve you breakfast the receptions
to Chucky wind was going to pay for the
light and he used God Jesus dude who's
gonna pay for the oxygen you breathe the
loitering of your bedsheets the water
rates maybe I should tell my staff they
will be featured in your video in lieu
of receiving a payment for work carried
out while you're in residence lucky for
us we to have a significant social media
following we have a hundred and eighty
six K followers on our to Facebook pages
and estimated 80 K on our snapchat there
at UK on Instagram and a palm tree of 12
K on our Twitter but Jesus Christ I
would never in a million years ask for
anyone for anything for free I also blog
a bit which as far as I as I'm aware is
another way of saying writing stuff on
the internet the above stats do not make
me any better than anyone so for me the
right to not pay for something everyone
else's has to pay for it starting what
they're asking for in the future I'd
advise you to offer a pay your way like
everyone else and if the hotel in
question believes your coverage will
help them maybe they'll give you a
compliment Oakland is sweet this would
show more self-respect on your part on
let's face it it would be less
embarrassing for you here's a little
video I produce with which you may learn
from best regards Paul Stenson yes the
answer is no and then the link that he
puts the here's the little video that I
created it's a video mocking this exact
situation like
he hired like some actress to play a
social media influence help Patty's and
then like the whole thing is just like
her on her phone and like hi guys so bla
bla bla and then it cuts to like her
being everything she's like as a
social-media influencer I am always
getting free stuff and I always like
whatever yeah you know you know what's
crazy cuz we all own businesses outside
of YouTube and I know the value of
social media because outside of us
promoting our own concepts we get brand
deals we get sponsorships people pay for
our access to our audience and all that
so it is definitely a service her
numbers aren't low yeah she has a good
following what eighty thousand subs on
YouTube and then $72,000 Instagram good
for me I find that worth a free room I'd
be grateful I'd be like y'all thanks you
just take a free room cuz most people
they have to give them a free room and
they have to pay them money because it's
advertising yeah so for them to like be
value that and be like you want just
free [ __ ] I'm like how do you own a
business what the [ __ ] and then you're
like you're like dick-measuring what
they're like oh I got a hundred or
something bowels and sobs they do let me
show you guys a shortened version of her
response to this so she posted a
17-minute video she's clearly very like
emotionally invested in all this so that
kind of sucks too though don't hold back
and forth like as an influencer if you
deal with someone that doesn't really
understand I I don't really see I mean
as a person as a human being I'm like
damn this hotel owner is hella petty and
sour but as a professional as a
influencer I would just buy oh they
don't really understand the game they
don't understand how strong marketing
kit could be and I would just ignore it
and cut it off professionally and I
wouldn't even promote them anymore so
let me mention a few things so she
mentions that she didn't want to say
anything about it at all but then it
just like bombarded everything like
everything like she just at this point
she was in my opinion she was kind of
cornered into saying something cuz
everyone could see her name and all oh
that's one thing and in another
is that a lot of people and even himself
the owner of the hotel was like thank
you now everyone knows my business
because you just explore exposed me even
more and then people like us like right
now what we're doing right now is we're
exposing as business even more so if you
loving this right now but first let me
show you this [ __ ] let me show you
I'll never go to that place white mousse
never Oh what's with their eyes
oh it's Jana she had eye surgery so
ignore that part but here we go over the
last couple of nights
My partner Connor and I have been
discussing going to Dublin for a little
weekend away that weekend before
Valentine's Day and I decided to contact
some hotels asking if they would like to
collaborate ie basically I go visit them
they stay in the hotel I feature them on
vlogs I put them on my Instagram I talk
about the hotel I write a review in
return for a discounted or complimentary
stay I send a couple of emails out to
what look like the most gorgeous hotels
in Dublin they then decided to take that
email which I had written to them in
confidentiality and blast it over their
social media pages with nothing but
malicious intent they posted that email
but I had written to them with thousands
of likes of followers whoever basically
saying I was an awful person for even
suggesting that I get to stay there may
be a discount all for free
I have never had a feel like that in my
life when I first saw that I literally
felt my heart sink to the bottom of my
stomach
it is totally one thing when you run a
blog a social media page whatever is you
do and you put yourself out there
because you're in control of the content
that the people on the other end of the
screen are seeing but when something of
you is is taken from a confidential
message to a business but it's in a
business with a fully grown man running
this business and then blasted over
their social media pages I don't even
know they wanted they wanted they wanted
that post to blow up I don't Marina I
don't really know what their intent was
it was just malicious and nasty and it
didn't come from a good place
I cannot be clear enough that that post
was literally aimed for people to be
like what the hell oh my god what like a
disgusting freeloader like who does she
think she is she
upper south she think she's God's gift I
wasn't even gonna make this video I
wasn't even gonna talk about it at all
my social media I wasn't gonna make one
tweet but then I had some other bloggers
reach out to me these other brokers made
me realize this isn't okay
and you know what it's not just me this
is not just happened to a handful of
people this is something that is like an
everyday occurrence if you work as a
social-media influencer people often say
you're so lucky to get clothes sent you
free get this sent you for free go here
for free and it's like if you work in a
shop usually get what at least 10%
discount or something it is a perk of
the job but you still have to work your
ass off in order to get that discount or
to get that day out for free or whatever
you do wherever you are
luckily in the blogging industry it's a
very glamorous reward you're gifted
these amazing things from different
brands it is work it's not just like you
can do this thing that you're being
offered to be given for free and there's
no strings attached do you have to work
your ass off create content for that
brand content is worth watching to your
average person content is going to come
across as authentic as enjoyable as
predictable as funny as happy as
pleasurable to watch so it's the 70
minute video there's a lot of people
that are upset at her too because they
just feel like she's being a freeloader
is that your initial reaction is exactly
what people are just attacking her I
think um it's probably because there's a
lot of entitled social media people that
are used to brands throwing a bunch of
stuff at them and they make the rest of
us look bad but her she just seems like
business as usual that email was
professional and standard and what she
does is she's just basically fishing for
clientele if you build a relationship
with these brands you know first it
might be free stay but they're like oh
because you advertise with us we got
10,000 more customers or whatever it is
and it's like thanks for that now do
another video at our spot maybe we'll
pay you 2,000 bucks to do it her email
is
very standard business proposal email
that I read all the time but get anyone
that wants me to promote something for
them for like those brands and stuff
it's always like hey I love your content
so it would be in the reverse hey I love
your content would you be interested if
I gave you money and this the end this
product for you to review and yada yada
yada yada
so she's just riding that in Reverse and
she's just doing her own good you see a
lot of people the the thing that they're
really holding on to with her pitch is
the fact that she said last year she
worked with Universal Orlando in Florida
and it's been amazing for them a lot of
people are criticizing that saying like
oh yeah now you put Orlando Florida it's
a case study people like they they
always want to hear what's your last
precedence as a case study yeah so then
other people were saying like instead of
saying that like why don't you give like
actual statistics like that probably
would help us do you guys had mentioned
just now and then also the fact that
she's just asking for free like not even
discount and that's because they don't
understand they don't understand the
back end so it's not that that's that
you what that is and I'll be straight up
with you that's [ __ ] hater talk it is
hater it's straight-up hater calm oh my
god you [ __ ] freeloader give them
numbers and shut the [ __ ] up this is
this is what it is right I'll put it to
you like this so I do like these muffin
things right I promote these restaurants
they don't pay me [ __ ]
but legit there's like a restaurant that
I go to frequently and I just put them
in there just because I like the family
they have literally told me that dude
every day since you put that video
there's been somebody coming to this
restaurant and eating this that watch
your video that's right that's how
important our reaches they have a budget
for online marketing specifically a taco
shop right now that blew the [ __ ] up
because I promoted them at a two-dose
spot I can't even eat there anymore you
know like that's how busy it got you
know what I mean like these are our
reach is pretty damn strong and you know
for this to I mean obviously like with
her like it's just professionals but
what more do you want and it's not like
there's no power in it you know it's not
it's not free cuz it's a barter it's a
trade and I think I think what the what
like when we're saying all this if this
stuff - it's to give you some insight
and perspective and it's coming from a
very humble place because I think what a
lot of people that are writing these
things
in addition to being haters is that they
they're so brainwashed I guess to the
point that they don't even realize that
a lot of their actual celebrities that
they look up to do the exact same
influencers they're the very foot like
they don't pay for anything and they're
just as entitled or like their people
are hitting up these wrestling or hotels
saying like hey so-and-so was their he's
gonna expect this for free but it's you
know I think the difference is why more
more people are accepting it to the
celebrities is because they do have
people like it's usually their managers
but then in this new generation it's the
influencers writing their own write that
in addition to the older ones that
aren't so up in the YouTube space or the
social media space they just think like
oh well these are just kids doing [ __ ]
like they don't understand like the
impact that we actually do have again
and humbly speaking and it's not and the
thing that I'm getting irritated at is
the fact that the guy said for free it's
not for free it's not you're getting her
Network and her people to even check it
there are places that I've checked out
specifically only because I've watched
YouTube videos you don't mean like a see
nice that well I'm like I want to go
there you know and I mean it works on me
too all the time so the fact that I
think it sucks because they say free and
it is not free there are people that pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars that
ask for that reach and all this girl was
asking for was for a rule some of the
top ten youtubers that we know and you
guys know to get ten seconds on their
videos it costs two hundred thousand
dollars just to get that yeah and when
you see it it's like well some of them
just look like bedroom videos why is it
worth that much it's because it doesn't
matter what the quality of the content
is what matters is how many eyes are
watching so regardless if you get those
eyes from doing a vlog or you get it
from doing like a dude perfect video it
doesn't matter because advertisers see
it as you are just paying for the
eyeballs right and if he owns a business
and he doesn't understand that value I'm
like well tough luck but it you got to
get what at times because with me I'm
thankful if someone's like hey I'm
put put your drink on on Instagram or
whatever I'm like you want five more
drinks like the fact that I don't have
to pay for that and that's ten thousand
people twenty thousand people whatever
sick marketing it's very basic I gotta
do is be paid five bucks for the costs
thank you you know and another thing too
that she was mentioning a lot in this
video a lot of the people that were
hating on her and like just giving her a
lot of these like degrading comments
there are older people in the older
generation they just don't understand
the way things work now and she's just
saying like how do you expect kids right
now that are trying to make their own
way especially through social media
they're trying to create their own
business like how do you expect them and
I really go out there and do it things
when people like this expose them and
just like they don't understand the
market or the industry at all and it's
just it's hindering the growth of well I
think it's a combination of them being
old but them not being entrepreneurial
because there's a lot of old people that
get it because there are all people that
work for major corporations that are in
marketing that are in advertising and
they get it because they're dumb exactly
it's like already thrown in their face
but they don't see it like it was right
over their head exactly
have there been comments defending her
time all the time majority a time yeah I
mean the part that stands out to me the
most is like outside of the whole
advertising and social media influence
your stuff is just how the owner replied
and how unprofessional
if she was very self-centered very like
douchey and entitled and she wrote to
like someplace like the ritz-carlton
they would probably just reply it we
humbly decline your offer and then move
on that's it they wouldn't go oh my
[ __ ] god check what check out with
this person room and then make a video a
little bit more background on this that
owner in this whole hotel here they have
previously just [ __ ] on vegans and
like gluten-free people and like they
just like [ __ ] like this is their
thing that's why I loved her like the
Logan Paul of hotels yeah
this was the the response here would you
like to read it
Thank You bloggers I just like to say a
huge thanks to all the bloggers for
their hard work or the past two days to
publish it you're giving us is
absolutely priceless
but don't worry bloggers your work won't
be going unnoticed it will be featured
in my book how to get worldwide
publicity without spending a cent and
we're thinking of dedicating a full
chapter to you guys including
screenshots of some of your most
entertaining public tweets Facebook
posts and negative reviews it'll be some
chapter keep the hateful comments and
reviews coming and you never know it
could be you who has featured in the
book thank you bloggers I really
appreciate this apology what if the
owner is like a 13 year old kid everyone
just thinks as an adult no you know what
the funny thing is it's like when it
comes to business they think that if he
actually thinks when it comes to a
business like negative press is good
it's bad it's horrible dude that all run
yeah I'll run it to the ground
can't wait yeah and there are other
people too like conspiracy theories here
that wow this girl is a genius or wow
this dude's a genius because no matter
what like they both are getting a [ __ ]
ton of publicity so it's good for her
bad for him actually yeah it is great
for
[Music]
[Music]